la crise ukrainienne objet d'un autre
entretien cette fois entre les chefs de
la diplomatie américain et russe un
échange entre sergueï lavrov et anthony
blinken qui a une nouvelle fois tourné
autour des exigences de leur pays
souveraineté de l'ukraine pour les états
unis garantie de notre expansion des
troupes de l'otan à l'est pour la russie
plus de précision avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
l'entretien entre sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken a duré une trentaine de
minutes et ce qui est intéressant c'est
évidemment de comparer les deux versions
des deux parties prenantes à ces
échanges on commence avec le côté
américain où le département d'état a
publié un communiqué de quelques lignes
un communiqué finalement assez
similaires à ceux qui ont déjà suivi les
précédents entretiens entre les deux
chefs des diplomaties russe et
américaine on y lit elle que washington
appelle à maintenir le dialogue avec
moscou mais réitère également son
attachement à la souveraineté de
l'ukraine et demande des actes concrets
au côté russe écouter le secrétaire
d'état a exhorté à une désescalade russe
immédiate et au retrait des troupes et
des équipements de la frontière
ukrainienne il a souligné qu'une
invasion de l'ukraine aurait des
conséquences rapides et sévère et a
exhorté la russie à choisir la voie
diplomatique
et puis du côté de la diplomatie russe
le sujet important c'est la demande de
moscou d'avoir des garanties sur une
expansion de l'otan vers l'est et en
particulier en ukraine sujet sur lequel
est revenu le chef de la diplomatie
sergueï lavrov
avec une pointe d'optimisme et côté si
aujourd'hui j'ai confirmé à anthony
blinken que c'est un sujet que donc je
ne passeront pas sous silence nous
allons insister sur une conversation
franche sur une explication franche nous
voulons comprendre pourquoi les
occidentaux ne veulent pas remplir ses
obligations ou bien pourquoi ils le
veulent uniquement quand cela sert leurs
intérêts anthony blinken est d'accord
sur le fait qu'il ya un sujet à
éclaircir nous verrons où cela va mener
on voit donc qu'il ya une forme de statu
quo actuellement dans les discussions
entre moscou et washington le
porte-parole du département d'état
américain ed price dit que washington
attend désormais une réponse formelle de
mots coût aux demandes exprimées la
semaine dernière par washington à ned
price qui explique qu'une voie
diplomatique est toujours possible et
souhaitable mais à condition dit-il
d'une désescalade dans la région
[Musique]